Jane got a gun is directed by Gavin
O'Connor and stars Natalie Portman Ewan
McGregor and joel edgerton and is the
latest Western to remind us why westerns
are no longer popular this movie tells
the half Revenge half Redemption story
about a girl named Jane caught in the
middle of a love triangle with two men
and the evil group of guys led by you
and McGregor who are coming after them
to kill them all can mess with a lot of
things but you can't mess with Natalie
Portman on Christmas this is my house I
have to defend it in all seriousness
though this movie went through a lot of
production problems multiple filmmakers
multiple actors many years of production
hell it's open in the middle of January
in just over 500 theaters this movie is
being forgotten about instantaneously
and after having seen it it's for good
reason this movie is a long uneventful
listless bore gavin o'connor made the
excellent movie warrior i thought that
was a great film i like everyone in this
cast it's kind of an episode to Attack
of the Clones reunion with Portman
McGregor and Edgerton all in the same
movie and they're all trying with this
material but there's just nothing
compelling there in regards to that word
compelling one of my biggest complaints
with this movie is the incredible lack
of even trying to make you and McGregor
be a villain of any interest his
characters got nothing to him Natalie
Portman has barely anything to her as
well joel edgerton 'he's character in
this movie is definitely the one that
has the most background the one that you
can kind of understand and appreciate
the most everyone else just kind of
wanders in and out of frame which was a
massive disappointment with so much
talent on display in this movie the
movie has a somewhat interesting set up
and some okay visuals but for the most
part the direction of this movie is
surprisingly restrained and not
necessarily in a good way sometimes with
film it's very nice to see a director
holding back not letting himself be too
known with the way he handles the film
but with a Western like this you want to
make your film flashy you want to make
your film look really beautiful and
there's no real attempt to do that it's
all very standard and the only
explanation I can think of for that is
the original film
girl in Ramsey left the project after
some serious problems with the producers
and was in about one day's time gavin
o'connor was hired to replace her that's
not a lot of time to get inspired about
the material you're about to film that's
sad actually these actors are trying I
don't look at this movie and say it's
bad because of the performances this
movie is bad because there's nothing of
interest occurring it's a long bore it
could have been so much more there could
have been so much more fun to have in a
Western you want a western to be fun
remember Clint Eastwood's great westerns
from the 60s that time is long gone I
mean even like open range by Kevin
Costner that was a really good Western
Django Unchained there's a great western
if you want to resurrect the western
genre and have it not be a film that I
go to see having no one else in the
theater opening in less than a thousand
theaters with all of these big names
this is not the way to handle that and
last but not least the most
disappointing thing about this movie is
that with the title like Jane got a gun
you'd expect her to you know do
something the majority of the action in
this movie involves her getting rescued
by somebody it's it's sad I'm gonna give
Jane got a gun a d-plus guys I wanted
this movie to be good I specifically
sought this movie out hoping that it
would be good that it could rise above
the problems that it had in production
but it just didn't so guys behind me is
some DBZ merchandise you know what that
means tomorrow as in Sunday I'm going to
be releasing Dragonball Evolution my
hilarious 'ti I've never reviewed it in
that format I've put together a little
teaser for you enjoy
you
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I can't wait to share that with
you if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes